schwere steuerhinterziehung so lautet
der vorwurf gegen sechs ehemalige
beziehungsweise aktuelle verantwortliche
des dfb
in fünf bundesländern kam es heute zu
diesem comment unter anderem in der
zentrale des dfb und in mehreren
privathäusern die frankfurter
staatsanwaltschaft hat gemeinsam mit
beamten der steuerfahndung des bka und
der bundespolizei in hessen bayern
nordrhein-westfalen niedersachsen und
rheinland-pfalz durchsuchungen
durchgeführt und bei mir im studio jetzt
unser sportchef matthias brüggemann
denn manche ist die frage ist was ist
jetzt sehr konkrete vor fast genau soll
passiert sein
es geht um einen vertrag der am 11
dezember 2013 geschlossen wurde zwischen
dem dfb und der vermarktungsagentur
infront
da hat der dfb das recht verpachtet das
in front zukünftig die werbepartner für
die werbebanden suchen darf und da
entsprechend auch geld einnimmt der dfb
hat also für dieses weitergeben der
werbebanden rechte eine einmalige summe
von infront bekommt und das ganze als
verpachtung deklariert das hätte den
vorteil dass das geld steuerfrei ist für
den dfb was er da bekommt dann soll der
dfb aber laut ermittlern trotzdem noch
einfluss darauf genommen haben welche
werbepartner auf den werbebanden laufen
und das ist letztendlich der punkt wo
die steuer ermittlungsbehörden gerade
sagen moment mal
jetzt ist es nicht mehr nur noch eine
reine pauschale verpachtung der
werbebanden sondern jetzt ist es ein
aktiver geschäftsbetrieb vom dfb und
dementsprechend hätte das geld was dort
verdient wurde auch versteuert werden
müssen und wir reden da jetzt über 4,7
millionen euro die möglicherweise
hinterzogen worden sind ein ganz
entscheidender vorwurf ist noch der der
von der oberstaatsanwältin nadja niesen
in der erklärung erhoben wird nach den
bisherigen ermittlungen besteht der
verdacht dass die beschuldigten von
dieser steuerlichen unrichtigkeit
wussten sie aber bewusst wählten um dem
dfb hierdurch einen steuervorteil von
großem ausmaß zu ermöglichen also das
klingt schon nach hartem vorsatz gemacht
deswegen gab es ja dann heute insgesamt
200 beamte die diese steuer razzia in
ganz deutschland durchgeführt haben
unter anderem in frankfurt in der
zentrale aber eben auch in privathäusern
wissen wir bei wem dort alles jetzt das
haus durchsucht worden ist
wir wissen jetzt von sechs
hausdurchsuchungen und zwar bei den
damaligen und heutigen generalsekretären
das war damals helmut sandrock heute ist
es friedrich kurz muss außerdem bei den
schatzmeister wieder einmal zu dem
damaligen zeitpunkt das war der herr
reinhard grindel und heute stefan
osnabrück und zusätzlich bei den beiden
damaligen übergangs präsidenten des dfb
reinhard rauball und rainer koch das
sind also die sechs personen bei denen
heute hausdurchsuchungen stattgefunden
haben ob sie auch beschuldigt werden das
haben wir bislang noch nicht bestätigt
bekommen aber dort wurde durchsucht und
entsprechend akten heute vormittag
mitgenommen einnahme der jetzt gerade
bei dir aber nicht gefallen ist ist der
ehemalige dfb- präsident wolfgang
niersbach der ja genau in der zeit über
die gesprochen worden ist präsident war
warum wird bei ihm jetzt nicht
durchsucht oder nicht ermittelt wissen
wir da schon etwas zu also wir wissen
bislang nur das nicht durchsucht wird ob
möglicherweise ermittelt wird wird der
tag noch zeigen ja wolfgang niersbach
war dfb-präsident als dieser vertrag und
den es jetzt geht geschlossen wurde
er ist aber am 9 november 2015
zurückgetreten im zuge der sommermärchen
affäre und die jahresabschlüsse die sich
jetzt auf diesen zeitraum beziehen die
wurden dann unterzeichnet und damit auch
verantwortlich unterzeichnet von den
beiden übergangspräsidenten rauball und
koch wir kennen das alle von unserer
steuererklärung wenn man dann wäre
derjenige der unterschreibt auf den
gegner noch zu wenden unrichtigkeit
möglicherweise festgestellt werden also
es geht um die jahre 2014 2015 und
niersbach ist eben im november 2015
zurückgetreten vor dem amt jan bosses
gerade gesagt stattdessen hat an einer
frau war das alles unterschrieben und
genau deswegen wird heute auch sein haus
durchsucht vor ort ist für uns mein
kollege andreas wegener in dortmund
andreas was kannst du uns über die jetzt
laufende hausdurchsuchung sagen was
spielt sich da gerade ab ja hier sind
heute morgen
sie sehen wir das anwesen von dr einer
traube er wohnt in einer kleinen weißen
villa einem parkähnlichen grundstück in
der nähe von dortmund wieder morgen
mehrere zivilfahrzeuge der hessischen
steuer verhandlungen
angekommen am geschält oktober hat ihnen
dann selber aufgemacht die ermittler
haben hier einen tisch aufgebaut vor dem
haus schleppen mehrere kisten mit
datenträgern und sonstigen
beweismaterial heraus man hat dr rauball
auch selber gesehen er spricht hier mit
den ermittlern und da wird natürlich
auch sauber dokumentiert was jetzt hier
sichergestellt worden ist und was nicht
und ansonsten kann man hier gar nicht
viel sagen also ein ermittler ist eben
zu uns gekommen hat uns darüber
informiert wie wir mit bildaufnahmen und
zufahrten zu gehen habe aber doch
rauball ist nicht erschienen um
irgendwas zu sagen
und insofern die maßnahmen laufen hier
noch und jetzt gerade aussieht kann dank
andreas wegener für dieses update jetzt
also vor dem haus von rauball
matthias sag uns ist das ganze jetzt
komplett überraschend gewesen hatte man
schon gehört dass da irgendwas schief
gelaufen sein könnte jetzt gerade so aus
als hätten sie sogar absichtlich gemacht
gab es da schon irgendwelche gespräche
darüber vorher war noch mal der
zeitpunkt heute ist schon noch ein
besonderer denn heute abend ist ja das
länderspiel deutschland gegen türkei in
köln
insofern alle dfb kräfte momentan in
köln unterwegs also schon auch ein
ungewöhnlicher zeitpunkt das länderspiel
zu machen
dieser vorgang dieser vorwurf der ist
bislang nirgendwo in den letzten monaten
oder jahren thematisiert worden was wir
wissen ist dass der dfb offenbar selbst
nach und nach ein schlechtes gefühl
bekommen hat bei dieser art der
versteuerung denn für die jahre 2016
2017 2018 wurde dann offenbar eine
andere versteuerung gewählt die
möglicherweise korrekte warum er die
jahre 2014 und 2015 in dem zuge nicht
auch nachträglich korrigiert hat auf
welche einschätzungen man sich da
verlassen hat auch das wird spannend
sein jetzt in nächster zeit zu erfahren
ja und in frankfurt vor der zentrale des
dfb steht für unsere jannik huber und
beobachtet die haben durchsuchungen dort
jannik laufen die durchsuchung noch
immer und vor allem was ist heute am
vormittag alles schon dort passiert ja
also wir haben es mittlerweile die
gesicherten
informationen das um 9 uhr hier alles
angefangen hat also bundespolizei
staatsanwaltschaft und steuerfahndung
einmarschiert sind die sind aktuell noch
drin bisher gab es da auch wenig
bewegung
einziger vorgang jetzt bis jetzt dass
die hessische finanzverwaltung um genau
11 39 auch hier vorstellig geworden ist
mit einem koffer unter blauen kiste die
damen und herren die dann hier
vorgekommen vor gefahren sind haben
beide das erstmal direkt hier auf dem
platz verloren jetzt aktuell noch ein
anwalt vom dfb hier gerade eingetroffen
im taxi neben mir und wir erwarten jetzt
dass es im laufe des nachmittags dann
soweit sein wird und das dann ja auch
kisten rausgetragen werden und so das
beweismaterial zur verfügung steht
vielen dank yanick für den moment du
wirst uns natürlich weiter auf dem
laufenden halten dankeschön
vielen dank auch die matthias für diese
einblicke also in die vorwürfe gegen den
dfb alles weitere natürlich dann immer
aktuell bei bild danke mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau dir
das nächste video an und vergiss nicht
zu abonnieren